[Music]
tell me that you're getting them I'm
getting it I'm getting it I don't know
what it is but I'm getting it
hey there cinephiles I'm Mark Ellis and
welcome to RT Essentials today we're
kicking down the doors to The Mouse
House to give some credit where it's due
because not all Disney movies have
received the attention they deserve and
we are not about to let that slide not
that we're pointing our White Glove
Mickey fingers at anyone there's many
factors that might lead a film to
falling out of the Limelight maybe it
was just ahead of its time or
misunderstood maybe folks just weren't
memeing their meanest of memes and
really how else do we find out about
anything these days whatever the reason
may be these animated and live action
films deserve their time in the Sun so
let's give it to them these are the
underrated Disney movies you need to
check out Atlantis the Lost Empire
any last words
yeah I really wish I had a better idea
than this
we're losing altitude light and the low
that's it unless someone wants to jump
ladies first
up first is Atlantis the Lost Empire now
I don't want to hear any Sly Atlantis
puns saying things like this movie got
lost at the box office even if that is
sort of what happened it last premiered
in the summer of 2001 and was competing
with the recent release of Shrek which
was a Monumental hit additionally Disney
went in a different direction with this
one and decided to make it more of an
action adventure as opposed to a musical
like most of their previous films this
was indeed a gamble because audiences
typically rely on Disney to deliver the
bangers I mean who doesn't want more
Hakuna matatas and you'll be in my
hearts couple that with Atlantis
lackluster critical reception earning
reviews like this one from variety and
I'm quoting here this blandly conceived
and executed attempt at a Juve style
Indiana Jones with Jules Verne trappings
recycles familiar adventure and cartoon
devices with minimal wit and flare whoo
tell us how you really feel
what are you doing you do swim do you
not oh I swim pretty girl pretty good
pretty good it's good swim good pretty
good I swim pretty good good it is a
fair distance to where we are going hey
you are talking to the belly flop
champion
we're wasting time
no poor reviews in an unimpressive box
office run can well sing a movie
possibly even bury it in the sea of
Cinema history see I get to make
Atlantis puns because I actually saw the
movie did you oh you did well if you did
you'd know that it deserves a lot better
than what it got it told a compelling
story about a young linguist named Milo
who had a crew of mercenaries to the
lost city it utilized the visual styles
of Mike mignola the Comic Book Creator
behind Hellboy and it featured the
expert voice acting of Michael J fox
James Garner and Leonard namoy sounds
like a classic to me lack of bangers
aside it's not too surprising that
Atlantis the Lost Empire has gained a
cult following in recent years with
critics reevaluating the film and
finally giving it some long overdue
praise holes all my life I seem to be in
the wrong place at the wrong time
my grandpa San Leonas II says it's all
because of this 150 year old curse
the wrong
kind of helps if you can blame it on
something
Paul's was an adventure dramedy released
in 2003 and based on the novel the same
name written by Louis sachkar it's about
a boy named Stanley yelnet who along
with his friends is forced to dig holes
at Camp Grand Lake a correctional
facility in the desert the digging is
enforced by Warden Louise Walker played
by Sigourney Weaver and after seeing
what she did to some of those Xenomorphs
and Aliens I would do whatever that
woman tells me director Andrew Davis
known for his action thrillers above the
law and the fugitive managed to make an
unpredictable film that appeals to
children and also touches on some
serious issues like greed and racism and
this one stays true to the book largely
due to the fact that the book's author
also penned the screenplay and who would
know the source material better than the
source materializer
thank you
[Music]
since the book had already attracted an
enthusiastic following particularly
middle schoolers holes was slated to be
a box office success and it was the film
earned over 71 million dollars against a
budget of 20 mil it also garnered mostly
positive reviews with a Washington Post
writing that one can't help but feel
thankful that the movie doesn't always
go the expected route and that the
characters have a little more depth to
them than average I know what you're
thinking so Solid box office numbers
some rave reviews interesting characters
and a built-in fan base why is holes on
this list well because it's that good it
should be in the Hall of Fame of Disney
Classics and it just hasn't received the
proper adoration but it is now streaming
on Disney plus so what are you waiting
for
dig in the Hunchback of Notre Dame
snooping around here trying to steal
your girl my girl Esmeralda dark hair
works with a gold remember oh yeah I do
wait a girl lover boys love her boy oh
no no no no no don't be he's all modest
look I appreciate what you're all trying
to do but let's not fool ourselves
ugliest face in all Paris remember I
don't know if you've watched The
Hunchback of Notre Dame or Notre Dame
for purists lately but it's a
surprisingly dark animated film heck
it's dark for any kind of film based on
Victor Hugo's 19th century novel of the
same name it follows Quasimodo The
disfigured bell ringer of the Notre Dame
Cathedral who bides his time locked away
in a tower his only friends are the
Gargoyles which is cool and all but more
than anything Quasimodo longs to be with
other people oh he also longs to stand
up to his Sinister father Claude frollo
who wants to commit genocide against the
Romani population in Paris and aside
from genocide the film also explores
infanticide damnation and sin uh you
know typical Disney Fair despite the
unusually dark subject matter audiences
still flock to the theater not sure what
that says about our society The
Hunchback of Notre Dame grossed over 325
million dollars and that was the fifth
highest grossing film of 1996. the
film's musical score was also nominated
for an Oscar and a golden clothe
you fight almost as well as a man funny
I was going to say the same thing about
you that's hitting a little below the
belt don't you think no
[Music]
touch touche
I didn't know you had a kid well he does
he timely to soldiers uh I noticed okay
but surely the critics must have hated
it otherwise we'd be talking about this
movie as much as we talk about say The
Lion King and I can talk about The Lion
King a lot like way too much for an
adult actually the critical reception
for the Hunchback was overall positive
Time magazine called it a grand cartoon
Cathedral teaming with gargoyles and
treachery hopeless love and tortured
lust ooh cheery the real reason
Quasimodo and the bells of Notre Dame
don't ring as loud as they should many
felt that this film was inappropriate
for children it even sparked boycotts
and thousands of parents banned their
kids from seeing it but with animated
content growing um increasingly darker
and more elevated in the years it
followed it seems that the Hunchback of
Notre Dame was just way ahead of its
time well anyways that's my hunch Sky
High
[Music]
hi okay
super spit sidekick
acid spin zero
hero and a handsome one at that
get out of here knucklehead Sky High was
directed by Mike Mitchell and co-written
by Kim Possible creators Bob Schooley
and Mark McCorkle said at a school in
the sky where students learn how to be
superheroes we meet Will Stronghold who
lands in a class for students who shows
special promise his classmate Gwen
cozies up but will soon learns that she
has other motives and that her mother is
the villain who defeated his father
Steve stronghold the live-action film
starred Kelly Preston Michael angarano
and Kurt Russell and featured an
original soundtrack released by
Hollywood Records that mostly consisted
of cover songs from the 1980s like
rocket versions of I Melt With You and
everybody wants to rule the world like I
said before when we show up to a Disney
movie we expect bangers
foreign
once again this film was designed to
appeal to both adults and children and
Mitchell mostly hit the mark on a budget
of 35 million dollars Sky High grossed
86 million bucks and critics praised the
writing specifically the humor and the
visual style BBC wrote that its
agreeable mix of knowing spoof and kid
pleasing fantasy makes it considerably
more engaging than some of the straight
superhero Blockbusters we've suffered
recently not exactly sure which movies
they were throwing Jabs at there but Sky
High was released in 2005 so we can
probably do the math though this was a
fun film with many positive qualities it
doesn't exactly jump to the Forefront of
our minds when we think of a Disney
classic but in the world of modern
Cinema where superhero movies are now a
dime a dozen some releases are simply
overshadowed no matter how high they fly
The Emperor's New Groove hey Croc can
you top me off Val be your friend
now about you find anywhere
that's that's gonna be tough where's
your I don't know let's face it you know
spring chicken
and I mean that in the best possible way
The Emperor's New Groove was an animated
comedy directed by Mark dindo and
written by David Reynolds who co-wrote
Finding Nemo it's about the Arrogant
young Emperor Kuzco who was transformed
into a llama by his power hungry advisor
the diva isma stranded in the jungle
cuzco's only chance to get back home and
reclaim the high life he Longs for rest
with a kind-hearted peasant named Pacha
together they work to return Cusco to
the throne but they must work fast
because isma will stop at nothing to
prevent that from happening this was a
fun one it featured the voice talents of
David Spade John Goodman and Patrick
Warburton AKA Putty from Seinfeld high
five the tone is warm and funny with
plenty of gags and especially hilarious
Dynamics between spade and Goodman's
characters Newsweek wrote that the
unfussy tossed off quality actually
helps give this original story zippier
reverence some of Disney's Pusher
cartoons lack at both Newsday and the
BBC called it the best Warner Brothers
cartoon ever ever made by Disney okay
bye-bye
are you okay you all right yeah yeah I
think I'm all right good
Heck on your promise
yeah thanks for kidnapping me and take
me to your village which I'm still gonna
destroy by the way
no touching
that's what they're really saying is
that The Emperor's New Groove was unlike
anything Disney had ever produced even
the title felt out of place and let
people confused as what the movie was
actually about couple that with over a
half a decade of substantial development
hell look up the film The Sweat box at a
poor marketing campaign and you have a
movie that was doomed to never find its
Groove though the film is considered a
box office failure it received a mostly
positive critical reception and the cult
of Cuzco seems to be growing stronger in
time with many now regarding The
Emperor's New Groove as a forgotten
classic which is kind of what this list
is all about The Rocketeer
foreign
next up is The Rocketeer a superhero
fantasy film that follows Cliff's Accord
a cocky stunt pilot in love with a
beautiful actress named Jenny Blake When
Cliff discovers a jet pack hidden in a
biplane he straps on the rocket Dons a
flashy helmet and becomes the high-fly
titular hero known as The Rocketeer it
sounds like a literal blast until the
Nazis show up and ruin everything by
wanting to use the rocket as a weapon
now Cliff must use his powers to protect
Jenny and prevent evil forces from
prevailing the film is set in 1938 Los
Angeles and was based on the character
of the same name created by comic book
artist Dave Stevens who is known for his
pinup style illustration Stevens had
sold the film rights to the character as
far back as the early 80s but much like
The Emperor's New Groove and many more
movies before many of them followed in
fact this one the language and
development held for years you got your
creative differences your endless grip
revisions Executives sacrificing certain
qualities of the character so they would
appeal more to the kids and increase the
potential for selling toys yada yada
yada finally the film is green lit but
didn't start shooting until 1990 and
wasn't released until the year later
almost a decade after Stevens had sold
the character rights
[Music]
[Music]
Unfortunately The Rocketeer was a box
office plot outshined by the success of
another superhero-ish movie Robin Hood
prince of Thieves released in the same
month oh that movie's really good though
and though many critics praise the
visual style and acting of The Rocketeer
the reception wasn't strong enough to
save the day but all was not lost Disney
will soon be releasing a reboot of the
cult classic on their streaming service
clearly this is a tale ready to not be
forgotten The Rescuer is down under here
we go we'll never make it
[Music]
please
prep comes to a full and complete stop
thank you
[Music]
The Rescuers Down Under was Disney's
29th animated feature film and the
second release in what has come to be
known as the Disney Renaissance this
Renaissance period lasted from 1989 to
1999 and consisted of several critical
and commercial music Centric hits like
The Little Mermaid Beauty and the Beast
Aladdin and the Lion King all of which
I'll point out had bangers but The
Rescuers Down Under didn't really hold
up to its peers and was considered a box
office flop earning just over 47 million
dollars worldwide compare that to The
Little Mermaid which grossed over
235 million the year before the film
follows Cody a young boy living in the
Australian Outback who frees a rare
golden eagle from a trap and soon gets
kidnapped by an evil poacher the obvious
answer to this uh you hire two Mice From
New York the hop on the back of the
clumsy Albatross fly to Australia and
save Cody and the eagle from certain
Doom all in a day's work
say where'd you get this pretty feather
boy
it was a present oh that's real nice who
gave it to you
it's a secret that's no secret boy you
see I already got the father
you just tell me where mama and those
little eggs are you might not be aware
but this film was actually the sequel to
Disney's hugely successful feature The
Rescuers released back in 1977. The
Rescuers also sparked a scandal in 1999
which resulted in 3.4 million videotapes
being recalled because someone had
placed an inappropriate image in the
background of one of the cartoons frame
I'd imagine that would just make people
want to buy the home video even more
maybe The Rescuers Down Under could have
used a scandal of its own because it
failed to receive the commercial success
it deserved despite its gorgeous
animation and delightful characters
dinosaur better let me do the thinking
from now on Amazon
hey they need help back here
I thought my brother treats newcomers
no matter how Charming they are you sure
know how to catch a girl's eye there
stud you know we love us a dinosaur
movie here at RT Essentials and Disney's
appropriately titled Adventure film
dinosaur is no exception it's the story
of alidar and Iguanodon raised by a
family of lemurs mice playing on birds
dinosaurs being raised by monkeys
scandalous adult images man I love
Disney back to alidar everything's
turned upside down when meteor strike
and his one slush habitat is turned into
a desert Wasteland now alidar in a herd
of other herbivores must Trek to the
nesting ground where water and
vegetation are still Bountiful but the
journey isn't made any easier by The
Vicious carnivores pour out for some
dino blood
[Music]
he's LED that monster right to us this
way
no don't move if we scattered
Stand Together
the film utilized the latest in computer
animation technology with Walt Disney
feature animation spending years
developing the software to create the
dinosaurs this ended up being the most
expensive computer animated film ever at
the time with a budget that exceeded
127 million dollars and it was worth it
because critics and audiences alike
praised the stunning visual but even
though dinosaur was a visual treat many
critics felt it was lacking in the
storytelling Department also Disney had
never made a movie like this and didn't
really follow it up with anything
similar not soon after it was released
anyway so it kind of feels like this one
was a one-off experiment that's easy to
overlook but like the dinosaur fossils
themselves this one deserves to be
discovered dug up and further examined
the Great Mouse Detective
now go
wrong
[Music]
be prepared dear viewer as we now enter
into Disney's dark era aka the Bronze
Age which lasted from 1970 to 1988 named
in part because of the many releases
that flopped during that time but also
because this era began shortly after the
death of Walt Disney The Great Mouse
Detective was released in 1986 and is
one film that despite being a product of
the dark era transcended to become a
commercial and critical success based on
the children's book series basil at
Baker Street the film follows rodent
super sleuth basil heavily inspired by
some guy named Sherlock Holmes who along
with his bumbling partner must worth the
evil radigan's plot to depose the mouse
Queen
[Applause]
I present to you a Statesman among mice
A Gifted leader
for justice freedom
time
the film was a turning point for Disney
saving the company after the massive
failure that was the Black Cauldron oh
that didn't do well either and it
allowed them momentum and resources to
propel into their Renaissance period as
we talked about earlier critics praised
the whip style and the menacing villain
rat again and that epic Clock Tower
scene was the first major use of
computer animation in a feature-length
animated film but despite the Great
Mouse Detectives many positive qualities
it has slipped from our Collective
cultural memories it doesn't take a
Sherlock Holmes to solve this mystery it
was just the wrong place at the wrong
time Hocus Pocus
[Music]
sisters be home
I am beautiful boys will love me
we're young
oh well
younger but it's a star
last but certainly not least is Hocus
Pocus the kids movie it's also a family
film a holiday movie comedy fantasy
horror it's got all the Blockbuster
sections covered and we're already
seeing that this one didn't really know
what it wanted to be so you got your
Tale of Three villainous witches Winnie
Sarah and Kathy who are resurrected by a
virgin teenage boy named Max in Salem
Massachusetts
all right you little trolley mom
Daddy
this will teach you to call people ugly
open your mouth
the film was directed by Kenny Ortega
now known for High School Musical and
the cast included Bette Midler Sarah
Jessica Parker and Kathy najimi lots of
other towns behind this one but it
didn't seem to matter because Hocus
Pocus was just cursed the movie bombed
to the box office and the reviews were
mostly terrible The Washington Post
called it two movies a sophomore a caper
for teenage boys and a dark Lark for
fans of Disney farce and Abracadabra
Sister Act both of them are failures
unsurprisingly this release was quickly
swept under the rug however no one could
have predicted that Hocus Pocus would
Garner a cult following in the
subsequent years with strong annual DVD
sales especially in October and record
broadcast viewing numbers how magical
and that wraps up our list of underrated
Disney movies as always we could include
every feature that fits the bill there's
far too many deserving Mouse House
Productions and far too little time but
still Sword in the Stone Robin Hood come
on we got plenty more episodes of artsy
Essentials coming your way so stay tuned
I'm sure we'll get to them eventually
thanks for tuning in I'm Mark Ellis and
remember all your dreams can come true
if you just have the courage to pursue
them and maybe a little Cricket on your
shoulder to encourage you
[Applause]
[Music]